oh my god a hundred point left a
thousand five hundred views my other
videos posted around I get twelve use
twenty-one you guys all watching this
video am i under something here alright
I made I'm making this video to address
the comments in this video because a lot
of people have been commenting and
watching it and I don't know Oh Joshua
fluke fluke commented himself ah that's
awesome
maybe that's why so many people are
watching it it's just because I'm
creating drama on YouTube it's the one
thing I did not want to do
oops oh well so alright let's let's go
through the comments I want to make this
quick and I'm just gonna kind of clear
up anything I see that I think might be
I don't know misguided or wrong in my
opinion
so just gonna just go and talk and say
stuff so yeah it's gonna be too long to
read all this yeah I read all this
before and replied and you can go read
all these if you want just oh yeah
it's funny that oh my god Joshua fluke
and some dude get into like an argument
on here I don't remember where is it I
want to find this maybe it got deleted I
don't know anyway it doesn't really
matter to me
that much I'm you know I'm more of just
I care about coding and engineering and
technology Isis I don't I can't even
manage to make videos very often because
I well just let's get back to the topic
that's called hard truths he's honest
and and yeah business business okay I
don't know I think everyone's really as
this guy's has such a robust respectful
comment section those who agree and
disagree are so respectful to
other nice shout-out to Joshua Joshua
gang yeah he's a cool guy I mean he
seems like a cool guy but that's not
really what this is about
or anything I don't know what this is
about honestly I just you know I just
made the video off the top of my head
after watching some of his and Here I am
so I don't I don't know what I'm doing
or what kind of consequences these
actions have ultimately I just want to
you know get better at coding and the
things I'm working on it continue my
sciency life of studying all the time
and then go take a nap whatever they're
that comfortable look in bed say
sarcastic stuff on this every once in
awhile and here we go I guess when I
make a serious video things actually
happen yeah I know I need to do I need
to do coding programming memes some
people seem to like those I'll do the
one of those maybe next or something
anyway let's keep going here there's a
couple and specifically that I hadn't
responded to it because I think I have
to stop responding to these like it
always it every time I see a new comment
on this it always reminds me that this
video has nothing to do with my channel
and probably shouldn't be on my channel
and so I don't know and now I'm doing it
again am i doing it just for reuse now I
get it I get it Joshua I get it you know
I think I subscribed you channel when I
was a new dev and I wanted to learn more
about JavaScript and web building and
eventually it turned into corporate
cringe which is great it's great content
but it's not what I signed up for and it
honestly doesn't really matter to me you
know it's good for a little laugh here
and there but it's not all that useful
really all right
let's list comment Rati well says number
one not everyone is the same in a
company yeah no [ __ ] I'll get back to
that skills matter first you may be the
nicest person that skills matter and I'm
not talking social skills oh yeah
yeah I mean how can you say no to
obvious statements of course skills
matter why wouldn't they
yeah being nice helps but also honesty
helps and sometimes you got to be mean
to be honest and social skills are
always good and like you work with
someone that's super good at something
and they have the worst social skills
and they they smell like a unwiped arse
when they come into work II forget it
just tell them to stay home and diss
your child maybe that's how you get
remote positions you just go in like
that but be really good at your job
until people are like okay you can do
the job just get away from me if you can
have your to be you're gonna have all
right three people want power especially
those who have the power don't care
about people everyone is expendable well
people do want power I agree with that I
mean never played a video game it's all
about having the power god mode control
okay but yeah I mean they're extremists
like I don't know televangelists and
stuff like control minions but everyone
is expendable I don't think that I mean
I don't I don't want to really expand on
that but it's a generic statement that I
couldn't agree with everyone is
expendable and everyone's a lot of
people that's like how many people were
in the world every single one of ever II
one is 100% word so I'm gonna say hard
no for only suckers sacrifice their
lives for the sake of the company unless
cereno very well-paid position isn't it
the same thing sacrificing the lady
weight sacrifice only suckers sacrifice
their lives for the sake of the company
okay let's start let's go with that I
don't know what's your life about there
are some people whose entire life is
their company and they would sacrifice
their life for and do and you know can
you really judge I guess you can't judge
but I I don't care you know
people can do what they want I'm not too
worried about it I wouldn't recommend
throwing your life away for a company
general I think you should go be happy
and work on that but okay let's go with
the second part though unless they are
in a very well paid position so it's
okay to kill yourself for a lot of money
we're going all right the world is full
of suckers who think we were all the
same nope we're not well we do share
some things in common I know it's hard
to believe but most of us have five
fingers on each hand ten total so we got
that in common
and most of us like to be treated
decently so that's I think what I meant
when I said that in the company when I
said like most people were kind of the
same I didn't mean like everybody wants
an Xbox because I'll be the first to say
I don't want an Xbox I just need a PC I
would never play the Xbox so you know a
lot of people like Xboxes you see this
this is even a point that is like so
ridiculous to go into because it's it's
just so obvious like whoo okay so I get
it though that's like the piece of my
little talk that people are picking
apart the most because it sounds kind of
the stupidest but I was just riffing I
don't know I I said it I didn't mean it
that I'm in it in the way that we have a
lot of things in common like you know if
you okay so if you want people to be
happy at a job you got to treat them
well and that's you know there might be
okay there's always gonna be that one
rare outlier that's like just rail into
me
just be really mean to me when I mess up
can you can you do that for me boss
there's always gonna be that one person
sure but in general most people want to
be like you know you gotta you gotta be
careful too of course because you just
don't know everybody and how they are so
you don't want to like do obvious things
that will be likely to trigger people
you know stuff like that I don't you
know it's such a broad concept it's hard
to even explain fully other than
everyone gets it it's just there's a few
people
let misunderstand it and yeah I think
what it comes down to is it's it's it's
a lot of this is about mental health
like it's it's really easy to get in
this cycle of like a downward spiral
type of cycle especially when things
aren't going well for you for a extended
period of time and you might say well
you probably don't know me very well you
might say something like what do you
know you have it easy like you said in
the video you always had no problem
getting a job well sure yeah that's
generally true but also I have purposely
chose not to take any jobs and well
about since the making of that video
because it was a couple months later
that I left the job I was at which was
an amazing job and I wish I could still
be there but it's I've had a lot of
family issues this last year and it's
been rough
it's been rough I don't want to turn
this video into that but let's just
continue let's him you know if people
are really that curious and I get a lot
of questions maybe I'll talk about it
more but ok so Kevin Lee he he respects
he has the respect all right I hope
people actually get my humor but
ultimately I don't mind if people don't
eventually they will or they'll just I
don't know whatever I'm talking way too
much this is gonna be useless content
how am I gonna post this his channel
used to be more about code than
criticism but he pivoted to that for the
views yeah it worked yep yeah and he's
doing well for himself and able to you
know you got to do what you got to do I
get it I mean honestly I wish his
channel or more about code stuff
personally because I'm more interested
in that but I get it I don't know if I
could do that maybe by making this video
I am doing that but I feel like this is
the worst cringy video ever
so I don't know I don't even know all
right
astrophysics dude you just jealousy
isn't honest about the war well - guess
what Josh is absolutely right Joshua flu
you should run for the President of the
United States of beating Trump okay ever
played to this guy and kind of mess with
him I said wrong channel
thanks for the compliment I don't ever
plan around precedent he said now I read
it correctly something directed towards
you which I knew obviously I was just
controlling him so it was just a
facepalm here I was like oh god he
actually thinks I'm an idiot
Oh God that's what makes it so awkward
missus even someone else that someone
else's comments higher confuse me I'm
just rolling back yeah I'm good so so we
we made up we're good man all right
hunts by chainsaw okay without even
reading the comment yet I'm being hunted
by chain salt this is pretty scary let's
see what we got here you're trying to
talk about things you apparently have
little to no experience with okay I'm
I'm really okay I guess I should be
clear here I'm not actually making this
video to defend myself because I don't
really have anything to defend against
other than the one thing of uh I when
people say when I said people are all
generally the same or whatever I think
that was obviously misunderstood but in
general yeah I'm happy to make mistakes
because that's how you learn I'm I'm in
that realm of engineer scientist weird
type guy that is okay with being wrong
because it's like hey that's the most
positive thing you can get you can find
out that you can do it better which is
great that's that's what I want okay
walk a mile and another man shoot before
you try to judge are you kidding me
I I mean that's the oldest say in the
book yeah you see things from other
people's perspectives but how am I
supposed to walk in Josh what flukes
shoes yeah I I have no
I've watched a lot of his videos about
his personal stuff and you know you
never know that the district story
everybody's got their unique experience
and stuff I hate but in general I feel
like I do a pretty good job of seeing
things from other people's eyes but also
you have to realize some people are just
crazy and you have no idea what they're
thinking and you have no way of truly
seen through the eyes until you realize
I don't know you see him on like one of
those crime shows is like bob was just a
regular guy going to work every day
he worked in IT he handled the back end
for some company one day his family went
missing and he was the only suspect no
one had any idea like that guy trying to
walk a mile in his shoes you would have
no idea right maybe there's some sigh I
don't know I'm just riffing here again
this is probably just I'm moving on I'm
moving on just cut cut when you say
people you say people are generally the
same oh yeah the same thing this comes
up all the time like everyone's comments
yeah generally I would say a good 95
percent of people or more you can you
can get a lot of generalizations like
you would like to be treated well you
would you you would like people would
say hi to you and you know just really
basic social stuff and if you make a
terrible blunder that is really foolish
you don't want to be ridiculed and
laughed at in front of the whole company
you know things like that you would
rather someone say he looks like he's
made a little error here and you know
you'd rather have it just pointed out
casually and not ridicule you know that
kind of stuff people are all the same in
that mode but like I said earlier in the
video and I guess I'll clarify again in
case anyone's confused there's always
that one weirdo that's like no ridicule
me take me out friendly company and you
know I don't know you can't you can't
pigeonhole everything actually you can't
really pigeonhole anything hardly but
I'm sure someone will come up with an
example
you can pigeonhole give me a good
pigeonhole coding problem okay well if
you believe that's true then you know
what I've said is true what so if people
are the same than what he said is true
what you saying all this talk I'm losing
I'm losing all right I think you should
feel guilty for having things easy what
you should feel guilty right I don't
think I have things easily I mean I
guess this video gives that impression
in some ways and I mean I felt pretty
good at the time because I had just
finished school and I just got a really
pretty I would say prestigious position
in a company you know it was I didn't
expect it but I worked hard for it I
studied hard you know it was a C++ job I
was kind of that was the thing that's
always always study that was all I cared
about they saw that in me and they gave
me the job
it wasn't easy I don't know anyone else
that studied C++ is hard so I'm not
gonna feel guilty I feel like I've been
hunted by a chainsaw
don't use capitalism as an excuse for
narcissistic greed I'm not even gonna
try to unpack all that what did I say
yeah it was a hot take not to be I meant
to be revolutionary overanalyzed yeah
yesterday sure in my opinion that some
things has changed well appreciate what
you're saying I don't care to elaborate
actually that's this is I think the big
comment that made me decide I guess I
should just make another video I don't
think many of my opinions have changed a
whole lot but my life situation has
changed and maybe I can explain some of
my points a little better I don't know
all right
jobless code or says I went through a
little hell last year looking for a job
I need easy to get a job then you are
most certainly an outlier especially in
this economy I feel I practically have
to bleed for my eyeballs to make any
money I you know and I replied this was
actually just happened a few minutes ago
I couldn't sleep so I was like I guess
I'll just make the video now all right
everyone's going through something
pretty generic statement it sounded good
in my head and realized probably know he
isn't helpful I feel where you keep it
up and he responded
yeah
so he just points out that if you only
experience bad crap you become hateful
over the world like Josh not my words
everybody thinks josh is hateful I don't
think you are Josh I think I get you
more nevermind I'm gonna go there and
pretend that I understand because I
don't I don't I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna go with I don't understand it's
easier that way
in my case my former former boss was a
criminal I've been there too actually he
was arrested and likely going to prison
prison but not before we managed to
destroy my life so Oh God
Oh Oh God well that's just one
experience I mean so my opinion is
objectively biased against companies
okay well I can you know bad experience
is a bad experience but here's the you
know you crack a hundred eggs you're
gonna get a few rotten ones I don't know
if that's gonna work for anybody I tried
I tried guys okay Shanice Braun this was
an old comment I agree completely I
commented from his divorce video and he
bashed me saying he was gonna roast me
even though I said was what even though
I said what I said was nice the truth
what we can't take criticism okay yeah
this was a long time ago oh this is
where the drama I was looking for at the
beginning the video started a little bit
I said I was you said I was obsessed
with sex and basically just sponged off
my wife based off no criteria come on al
ammo I don't even know I'm not even
gonna try and this yeah Josh my fluke
whoa how'd you find me
yeah all right well I'm not gonna read
all that there's more I don't remember
this okay Josh was a great guy etc but
there's one thing he doesn't know
everything doesn't know at all come on
guys
come on guys this is a nice respectful
comment section nice and I do love it
actually I do love these comments these
are things are a beautiful thing
thank you guys you've really made it a
lot better all right so what else we got
oh it's okay oh yeah I even said it yeah
I agree it's hard to plan before you
have kids on the way your girl guys okay
I can't I can't do any more I can't take
any more of this this has been fun
though and I'll try to do some more fun
videos this is just too much wall of
text for me to read all of it and keep
going that's basically what it comes
down to it's not that I don't want to
and I haven't before actually I haven't
read this one it's it's okay so I get
notifications when like new ones coming
up replies I don't actually know about
until I go manually see them so and I
don't really go through my comments too
often because well it might be a
combination of laziness and I have been
working a lot on my game engine and
trying to remove any distractions I
possibly can and it's actually rather
difficult so trying not to go on YouTube
is has been a goal of mine recently
you're misinformed he does not live with
his parents and there is a long story
behind what you are misrepresenting get
the full story before you jump on your
high horse there's a lot of these quotes
going on with people cute I don't know I
mean mostly yeah the comments are so
nice and friendly but there's a few
where people are starting to be like a
little yeah yeah yeah I know what I'm
saying fam god I can't believe I just
said that I'm joking I'm joking
alright I'm not that kind of channel
well I I think I should call it here I'm
probably gonna wake up my son talked in
it 6:00 in the morning it's okay it's up
in an hour anyway and we're gonna make
some bacon and eggs so there's my face
like a year ago I still have the same
glasses except they're more broken
all right well peace out guys hope you
enjoyed this video let me know what you
think and also don't forget to have a
drink on me peace out